All right, we're almost at the end now.
Hopefully you've had a lot of fun and
interesting experiences playing around
with Photocraft and
computation at the same time.
We've actually had a lot
of interesting lectures.
Hopefully you've enjoyed all of
the material we've covered so
far and all of the fun assignments
that you've gone through
to learn about the building blocks
of computational photography.
While the lecture part of
this class is over now,
I actually do want to say that I'm
going to be now adding on Piazza and
other types of sites, a variety
of additional advanced concepts.
These will be in forms of research
papers, websites and videos.
I do want you to look at all
of this material, study it and
engage with me and the rest of the class
in a variety of conversations on what
you think about these advanced concepts.
These are concepts that could be
practical to the kinds of things that
you've seen in existing
software packages that you use,
to much more researchy,
kind of pointing a direction towards
future of computational photography.
I'm going to try to come up with
a variety of interesting topics.
Again, my request is,
engage with this material on Piazza,
chat with each other.
We're going to have a lot of fun
trying to play around with a variety
of topics in this area.
But again, it's new advanced
concepts that I think you'll enjoy.
With that, I'd just like to say thank
you, it's been a lot of fun and
remember, have fun
computing with photographs.